q and now to conclude our debate I call
on vice president timmermans for the
Commission thank you very much ma'am
president just remarks on two issues on
the MFF I hope the signal given by this
Parliament and the Commission to the
council was clear and in very simple
words I would say it's an illusion to
think that the MFF should be more of the
same we want the same but more of it
that's not going to fly
we want the same but less of it is not
going to fly either
so we will have to find a compromise
where we do more on what needs to be
done now and less on what needed to be
done in the past and for that we need to
have a reasonable budget where we
convince those member states who say
they are frugal that it is in their
interest to pool our resources at the
European level to meet these challenges
and we convince those member states
who's think still cling to outdated
policies that they should embrace the
potential of remove moving that towards
new policies especially linked to
climate change this brings me to my
second point and also triggered by some
of the remarks that were made I want to
warn for a false contradiction that's
been put on the table by some here no
longer here but some who were here and
that is that there is a contradiction
between being ambitious on climate
policy and saving our industry I think
it I think it's exactly the wrong way
around the longer we take to embrace the
potential of this transition the more we
will hurt our industry and the potential
for jobs in the new economy I think now
that even Jeremy Clarkson recognizes
that there is a climate crisis I think
there's no more space for any climate
deniers anywhere so we know we're faced
with an existential crisis and we know
we have the collective responsibility to
do something about it and I think the
sooner we do this the sooner we put the
resources in
creating a circular economy in creating
new jobs in the new economy in helping
people transit from the coal mine
industry towards a new economy
the sooner we embrace that the sooner we
will come out of this as leaders in the
world and the sooner we can say to our
children and grandchildren we've heard
you we know what our responsibility is
we're taking it we're helping you create
a world that is better tomorrow thank
you thank you and now for the council
Minister two per annum members of the
Parliament for your remarks and comments
I will convey your messages to the
President of the European Council in
concluding let me outline a few things
in particular and may I start with the
presidency priority which was mentioned
several times by you namely the Ruth law
respect for the rule of law is the
corner stone of our union and as such
essential for its functioning as regards
to Hungary in particular we started the
article 7 hearings in September in
December tenor Affairs Council we will
organize a second hearing as a priority
the presidency has focused on preventive
action and on making our rule of law
toolbox as effective as possible
secondly as noted in this debate the
European Union needs to continue to
spearhead climate action and lead by
example in order to help raise global
ambition this means engaging in long
term transition to a climate neutral
economy such transition will bring a
profound and radical change in almost
every industry and the way we go about
our daily lives we know that we need to
provide the right incentives for this
transformation and we will have to make
sure that we leave no one behind
taking into account national and
regional specificities and different
socio-economic circumstances
and ladies and gentlemen within the MFF
context this will be reflected as part
of our negotiation toolbox we will
provide chest transistor and as
mentioned by some of you change the
balance is another issue that will be
addressed in our negotiation box as a
very important mainstreaming element and
thirdly the leaders will provide us with
guidance on the overall level of the MFF
we see Europe developing we see social
economic gaps being reduced meaning that
our ippolit our policies are effective
but it also means that the level of
support from the EU has to be adopted so
a realistic budget should be reflecting
this we as presidency we are committed
to propose an efficient and effective
budget in line with our citizens
expectations bringing genuine European
added value thank you very much madam
president for your attention and for
this valuable discussion